[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
pregame picks
the show where you the people at home
can win free cash prizes by simply
predicting
all the random [ __ ] that occurs in the
nba pregame
you know how we rocking tonight we're
giving away a lot of money we got the
warriors versus clippers it's going to
be a jam-packed night from your boys
let's get to these pics baby
lois what's
how crazy is that wait is that a three
let's see that's a three that's a three
step curry wow money i told y'all
welcome to pregame picks let's get it
[Music]
hey like i said welcome back to another
episode of pregame picks i am your host
pierre aka with the plug and as always i
am joined by my man
my boy a guy that's becoming big bro
famous lost what's popping brody how you
feeling sir what's up what up what up
what up what up what up what's up
i feel good pete where we on what we own
hey man
i i i'm feeling as good as you it's been
a week since the last time we seen each
other
last time he was able to give away a lot
of money so i'm hoping we can repeat the
same thing man a lot of people want that
money and tonight yes sir you're dealing
with your boy
tonight is your night because it's your
boy we got the warriors versus clippers
yes sir it's a stephanie
kirby hi are you uh are you excited
about tonight
i mean it's just another day of the
parts another it's just a regular season
game man
it's a regular season we
so listen listen before we get into all
that that [ __ ] and
our [ __ ] talking extravaganza we ran
a question and pre-production for the
people at home and if you just tuned in
make sure you let us know down below in
the comments
if you had to take steph or kawhi
for the next three years who would you
pick first famous lost as the steph
lover i have to know your answer and
please put the bias man watch your mouth
and let us watch your mouth when you
talk about me watch your mouth when you
talk about me i'm 31 years old watch
your mouth when you talk with me talking
to you hey
you're right i resp i respect my elders
i respect my elders i respect my elders
but can you answer the question
can you answer the question yeah i'll
take i'm taking steph next three years
if i'm gonna be starting a franchise
duh can you give can you tell me why
because he's deaf
that's it cause he's stuff
nothing else need to be said right what
else
you anatomy unanimous unanimous mvp
unanimous mvp unanimous mvp that's the
best point guard
ever to ever live i listen i agree
but the reason that this this
conversation is even is because some
people
on the internet say that steph hasn't he
hasn't carried the team he's had a lot
of help
you know what i mean he is the greatest
shooter of all time yeah yeah listen
listen listen
listen listen listen listen okay good
you just turned me up
hey we the same team we was losing with
we was we started winning with and steph
is the unanimous mvp so do not tell me
he can't carry a team
that same team that was losing with
draymond and clay
steph unanimous mvp yes carrick them
okay no no no no yeah to winning yes
they all played big parts but steph is
the unanimous mvp for a reason
he stepped for a reason the same team
that was losing
started winning it it makes perfect
sense and no trades
we got famous no superstar trades
happened
no superstar trades happens to win we
won with kd but we won before kdp
listen listen listen to yourself listen
to yourself
if you're saying they all played a major
part then how the hell
can you say that he carried them
unanimous mvp
unanimously i would say he was losing
what he when he won that award they
didn't get the
the jury they didn't get the ring during
the unanimous mvpc
but we won the year before it doesn't
but that sometimes people don't win
sometimes people don't win the
championship out at seven games
sometimes people
don't just because they was the best
team regular season doesn't mean they're
just gonna win
only this only is this age y'all listen
listen
i'm just i'm just putting it's not me
i'm just putting all of the things on
the table i put my ear to the street so
i heard what the streets was chirping
i was talking i'm trying but i'm just
the same team
listen the same team steph was not
winning
every game with he started winning
with and he's let's look at these
comments we got somebody
somebody said kawhi younger though
so [ __ ] uh not [ __ ] i'm sorry
i i can't read i don't have my glasses
on gonzales what you saying
said come on i thought it said he said
kawhi is younger though
he said he said hawaii is chugging so
hey
c gonzalez uh somebody else said kawhi
better defense
we see you know i'm sorry i'm so sorry
who's saying that my glasses are that
goofy
whoever said it yeah the defense they
goes
c gonzalez75 i got his name right he
said kawhi is younger though who said
i played better defense that's why i
take him
man if you don't get your goofy goofy
[ __ ]
what you talking about okay all right
let let's do this then let's remix it
right okay
we'll give you that one in the clutch
today
2021 who do you want
for the last shot steps down curry
or damien leather or damian lillard i
knew you was going to say that that's
all y'all want to talk
about yeah yes then y'all just see them
in the back point together look at
then y'all just seen
hey that's okay but this is a
competitive game this is a competitive
game so i want to know
famous loss for the last shot
who would you rather have we talking
just clutch steph is the greatest
shooter ever he has that but for just
clutchness
are you taking dame or steph and
everybody at home let me know in the
comments
let us know are you taking game or steph
who's the better shooter who do you want
with the seconds and the clock winding
down for the last shot lois i'm still
waiting on your answer
don't duck this one you can't duck this
one
you can't duck this one hey i
i think i think i think i got it oh wow
i thought i had you i thought i scared
you off set this man went and got a
steph
curry jersey
so you go so okay you mean to tell me
in your heart now that steph curry is a
better clutch shooter than damian
lillard in your heart i know that's your
boy but keep it up keep it a buck
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna let lois get
his [ __ ] together
uh everybody at home let me know in the
comments really dangerous damon's him
damn really is he taking that but steph
so you're taking but i'm still taking
steph
okay i'm rocking with dan i listen like
i said steph curry is the greatest
shooter i've ever seen but when we're
talking clutchiness
damien a little bit like no cat dog no
count though no cap though it is scary
how dang
and [ __ ] it is scary
it is it's scary he a lot of cold ass
people home he sent some crazy
some some talented teams huh paul george
is my favorite player he waved that man
bye-bye
had me shitty at home watching that he
said he said
uh james harden i mean not j i'm sorry
but uh yeah it was james harden chandler
parsons and that rockets team
bye-bye uh you know what i mean it's
just hey i don't know how you do it man
no cat though no cat though they they
might be the most clutch player in the
in the in the league right now though
like that right now going down hey i i
swear to god he might be the most
i'm still but i don't i'm still taking a
step
but they might be the most okay i'm
telling with that but see
with that buzzer you they know me you
got you got
you got some unconditional stuff love so
because of that
let's show this clip of you from your
instagram celebrating the three-point
contest win
by yours truly steph curry production
can we roll that can we show the people
at home how my boy famous love
celebrated
the steph curry uh three-point contest
winnings do we have that on fire yes sir
voila look at this man
man are we really surprised watching
watch them
watching are we really surprised i told
y'all if my boy was going to be in the
contest he needed to defend
[Laughter]
opposed the double team stepped a
three-point contest
hey listen somebody said last shot i
have to take steph a walker 34 said last
shot he's taking stuff a walker i know i
love stuff he's a smart steph
but damian lillard come on now somebody
said damn dollar for show i don't care
shout out to chub
love chub love what's going on my guy
bro what up charles
hey listen i i want to let the people at
home know
that you you good at what you do man
cause you just
i just watched you react to that hornets
game
when terry rozier got slapped in the
back of the neck
you was doing that and uploaded and
doing all that [ __ ] when we was i saw
you doing
it that boy don't take no days off while
he was sitting right here
getting ready for a show he was also
working on his instagram
no days off you don't get what lo said
by just sitting on your ass
hey but that's hey hey look but you
gotta think look this is going i'm doing
the show right here
[ __ ] them boys i'm doing this not not
the boys but
them boys them boys too but i do this
yeah and i'm posting that on ig
twitter facebook tick tock so it
i'll be you know i'll be trying i'm
trying to try to go global bro
i'm gonna go global no hey i'm i'm i'm
firsthand here
to witness your your hard work and your
ethic and your recording this in your
studio
that's a whole another story though we
got them boys on the court
we got the boys on the floor hey pg
shout out to pg in kawhi
hey pg braves my boy violate me that boy
bro
that's my boy oh my mama yeah he he came
a long way because when he first got
them shits they was a look
you know that was a lack of hang time
there
finally find the shape of a fine pg
shape
up the one from uh high school uh
college
you remember the show and
yeah yeah all weak as hell
did he go steph ran out first so he on
the air falls
step right out first
hey so now that we got steph out of the
court we get to announce our first
challenge
so we have the over or the under on
steph made threes during walmart
which is 10 and a half so do you think
steph is going to make over
10 and a half at 11 or do you think he's
going to have under
10 and a half threes over
everybody in the comments let us know
it's over
and i want so we got going
so no since you're saying over i'm going
under i think steph curry likes to goof
around we've seen him
be honest be honest with yourself hey he
he's
he's a silly goofy guy he may run around
and do something he's necessary
he just hit 31 in about in 30 seconds
about damn that 30 seconds
i'ma go under man i'ma go under for sure
for sure everybody in the comments let
us know so you can take home some money
um don't forget we have switched things
up we are not winning
and losing as a family anymore whatever
you think
based off what me and lo say put in the
comments and if you're right or you're
wrong you may randomly be selected
to take home some money look the clock
is ticking
he bouncing balls talking to referees he
over there
basketball right ain't nobody ain't
nobody doing that the
the flake gate ain't that's only some
tom brady [ __ ] ain't nobody doing that
that's all done nobody else check the
ball
please please pull up the clip when we
just watched lebron do the same thing
please please i talked about it last
time please
thank you lebron boys and warm ups
please
please watch this boy i know thank you
please watch you want hey what are you
doing
production uh has steph curry made a
three yet
are we keeping count yet no he bought he
has not made all right he's probably
gonna take a few layups first
he's gonna take a few layups first take
a few layups [ __ ] floaters and [ __ ]
like that first
that's what i'm saying so he might not
know he might not get the over
he might not get the over well how many
but he's gonna make that song
don't don't blink
don't oh my god oh my god
when was the first time you've seen
steph curry play be honest too don't be
talking about oh i wouldn't bought your
name but davidson no you wasn't
davidson did you know you was not you're
not watching matt davidson
did you not watch that day i did watch
it man dave i did watch him at davidson
yes sir
okay okay remember i'm from remember
north carolina before you are you are
okay so what about seth or is it just
steph curry love or do you just love the
whole fam
i play i play i play itself in them in
high school except play for charlotte
christian
i played them in high school but what
college did seth go to first before he
went
before he transferred to duke
what was that school it start with a l
what was that school he went to ah he
started with a i think it was
he went to like two right transferred
yeah
correct me if i'm wrong because
because he won't hey because i'm telling
you he started he started turning up
he went from he will forget to to a big
dog
i'll tell you for hey
shout out shout out to my shot town guy
he said he said he taking the under on
stuff because he does hella goofy [ __ ]
look like that what is that come on lois
what is that
you ain't y'all don't say [ __ ] when oh
boy oh boy they play football do that
i'm a cowboys fan that that got to get
them he got to get them hips new shout
out to dax just got the bag yes sir
cowboys nation stand up
but back to steph curry man we certainly
got a three yet and listen i don't want
to step up
[Applause]
what are you doing what the hell are you
doing i know
yeah yeah yeah and somebody's saying
over that's easy
okay devonte 77 it's easy okay i'm gonna
remember that
over for sure bastion sunoku that's one
i could tell the way it left his head
did y'all
did y'all missed out all right yeah
that's what i could tell the way that's
his hands
that's
so relax relax on my my production
people
lost ain't gonna miss nothing [ __ ] man
listen
i don't trust nobody but but the back of
my hand
split cat but that
put the back of your head
okay please don't miss ain't nobody
checking you nobody's checking you so
right
right now right now right now he's just
shooting right now he's just shooting in
the corner
but eventually i'm guessing he gonna
move around what would you say
potentially could be the longest
three-step take and we gonna judge off
the staples center
the logo right there me at court by what
you see with that about where the ref
is what a rabbit
damn you went to that level coach is
that a coach or a ref
that's a wrap i just ain't no you don't
go that far
so that's that's the s you see that
staple center you see
you see that statement hey hey hey hey
hey yeah but don't blink i told you
don't blink don't don't blink
look up he got hit him he don't hit 40.
don't bleed look up step
out 40.
he got hit about four or five in a row i
i hope when nobody
take another answer seriously i feel
stupid khaled
dj khaled dj khaled hopefully
hopefully somebody in the comments was
saying over for steph
uh because it looked like steph is two
away from getting oh
wait wait wait he stopped for a second
uh-oh
hey man it don't matter bro bye bye
it's over
well yeah steph due to his hair
hey i'm i'm getting worthy at the
backboard
it's pickaxe split that kiss over it's
over we gotta go
we went away we went away yes sir we
want to wait the steps
turn around
uh i don't know you're taking off the
wall i'm in the damn show oh [ __ ] might
get he just took
that [ __ ] my guess but listen to me
listen to me she might get a jacket off
look steph took a jacket off he took a
jacket off
after after he missed the layup he took
her jacket off
then he just shot that shot he took a
stumble he still got a shirt on
so he gonna take that like damn how many
shirts you got on bro the league funny
the league funny i feel that the thing
is funny on that
unnecessary [ __ ] just unnecessary
necessary
and i think that's number 11
right there so hold on
who knocked that in it's right there
then split cactus
boom
listen i'm so sorry for anybody that
went with me on the under i just wanted
to
argue with lost i like arguing with
those it's hard for me to even get
excited for that because i knew he was
going to hit 11 right
like steph curry hitting over 10 and a
half hey
we got to go higher next time for steph
curry we got to get him like 20 yeah
20 and a half now let's try let's try
that like 50.
50 relax relax that's the easy honda
that's it that's the easy idea let's try
50.
so now that we got that out the way
steph curry
he did the over the next one that we
have lost
is will he make his last shot i know we
usually do team
would a team make the last shot in
warm-ups but this is specifically for
curry will he make or miss his last shot
in warm-ups
while you think about that low so i want
to give a shout out to the five people
that are gonna be taking home
five hundred dollars for rocking with
lost and the over on steph curry threes
shout out to shark killer fifty shout
out to keith set out to bryce jr for
life i think you won before so you get
into that bag bryce
stay tuned in and then we got richie 21
and then we got
liam the bucks fan 51 who i also think
has won
shout out to them boys for tuning in and
rocking with me and lost and taking home
that bread
be responsible with that money don't be
tricking on no chickens if you
understand what i'm talking about
loss make or miss curry last shot
how you rock meg brother
mate i'm gonna go with the makers no
no no he gonna miss he gonna throw up a
long far distance three
he gonna bank up and then he gonna get
back to the line to say
uh the uh what do they call it what do
they call it when they the national
anthem
hey they got your twin ain't no put that
camera back on
on those twins put that camera back on
those twin right now please
y'all know i'm not even gonna say the
name i'm gonna just say it's twin i bet
you they get they know exactly what i'm
talking about lois
put that back on his twitter yeah
[Applause]
yeah look how loose that's right
that's my first hey pat dude
fat dude to himself first of all that's
my first cousin
but y'all can put put the picture right
beside each other right now we all look
alike
look at this
godly that man lost the first person i
ever seen in two places at once that way
out there at warm-ups and on the show
with me
my gosh that way get into the bizzy
put the camera put the camera on me and
pat right now i bet you won't look not
in the light
hey lois is you gonna make a miss your
next shot
oh never mind look like your ass might
walk to the locker room
that workout was too intense yeah i'm
taking a seat look look
at those jokes he said he said hell no i
can't make [ __ ] let me go sit down
for a second we can put this we can put
the camera back on steph
now that with me i'll probably be
that'll be i'll probably right now be
going headed to the back
six minutes left i'm done shooting
headed to the back getting extra
treatment massages and [ __ ]
look at that look at that's a
hey i ain't mad at you for being a
stuffed fan like you are that's a bad
man
that's a bad what you predicted for his
his uh stat line tonight
let me get let me get a stat line
prediction from you for for steph
well seeing that he averages 29
i'm gonna already gonna say he's
probably have more than that
so and it's the clippers pat bev was
checking him
he might go to the free throw line
okay so either he going to the
free-throw line a lot or
he's getting mad as hell that he's not
going to the free-throw line
so this is a very tricky situation but
he's gonna have 32
plus hey
32 for all our viewers at home y'all let
me know
y'all prediction on what steph is going
to have tonight as far as points and
assists if one of y'all get it right
i'm gonna do something out of my own
to give y'all a reward for that and i'm
gonna remember it but listen
we just got some exclusive content from
lowe's lows don't be br
loss is the king of player breakdown he
just gave y'all some insight on stuff
you see how he broke it down he said
listen he playing against pat beth
pat bev is super antsy here we know that
for sure
chicago in the bloodline all day so
because of that he gonna get to the free
throw line and we know what steph do at
the free throw
line he don't miss so that right there
is the easy 12 points
either then he may either either he's
going to the free-throw line or he's not
and that's gonna piss him off which
means then he gonna hit nine threes
which is 27 points by itself oh
yeah but but yeah but in all seriously
it could mess his mind up
and he might you know have a look he
could he could still have 29 but it
might be a hard
it might be a hard ass 29 you feel me
with a lot of shots
pause but hey if pac-man playing od
he going to move off the ball yeah i'm
29
29 yeah yeah yeah yeah even i don't care
if you take 25 shots
which he better take 25 shots every
[ __ ] game he better take 25 shots
every game
but if pat better foul and they're not
calling fouls he's going to play off the
ball
and when he started passing and playing
off the ball if they're not passing to
him
now it's going to be tough for him to
score because you know they're not
hitting them they're not hitting them
when he coming off the screens and [ __ ]
because he's not really on the ball no
more playing hella defense
so he passing coming off
everybody at home we got three minutes
left we down to the last three minutes
make sure y'all putting your picks
in for steph curry last shot is it going
to be a make
or miss me and lo so rocking with the
making step handle got five people
five hundred dollars already by saying
he would make over ten and a half threes
and warm-ups
that true to be right so five people
went home with 500
and the rest of y'all could go home with
some money too so make sure you put your
answer in the comments so you can be
randomly selected look
that's those for real he had to go over
there and get that boy
[Music]
they got bro i'm telling you that man
right you talking about me looking like
you said i look like who's seth curry
who else you said i looked like
i said i said i said i said self-dirty
hey but you're saying i'm corny yeah i
did say seth curry i said self
dirty let me move closer to the camera
he said seth dirty but got the nerd to
call me
corny seth dirty
hey mario made a living out of that
martin made a living out of it out of
changing people's names
with pam martin made a living out of
that yeah
except that was 40 years ago
yeah what you mean time may change watch
watch step three
do something productive with your time
watch that pull up
do something productive with your time
since you were never a hooper
watch one hey you were never one watch
one
so you you roll it with make right steph
curry gonna make his last
i think i i know your answer is it gonna
be a two or three it got to be a three
right it has to be a three no way in
hell his last shot of warm-up is
a damn two a layup or no way he's second
to mid-range
had steph curry taking one mid-range
this whole warm-up i don't think so
right it was threes and layups
correct he took a lot of he took a lot
of them
okay but okay so what you thinking is it
three
i hate i want to say two but it's gonna
be a three because you're gonna be
walking away
ain't gonna make it shout out to my feet
if
oh no keep going lows
if he misses it if he misses a shot he
gonna say damn i missed that
and then he gonna say let me get it back
and get another shot and then pull up
again and make
or oh
yeah can we see the last shot cause
steph curry just ran off which probably
means he made it no way in hell he's
running off court on him
hold on hold on hold on i think hold on
my phone ringing
yo is that steph
yes er it was ladies and gentlemen
i hope you all had makes an
accomplishment
yeah he said he said he bought it he
said he might have 40. that was stuff
oh [ __ ] that's crazy your phone just
went off
mine did too hold up
you know yeah
we got four seconds left though of
course i know yeah no no
i'm gonna call you no no i'm gonna come
who are you talking to who you talking
to
that that that was the real step he said
that was the real stuff i know that's
cap
i know this guy he's pc he's he said
that we go with the mate
and they ain't gonna say you like what i
did yeah we went with that like come on
man we got fast
was it a three was it a three yes it was
a three sir
yeah it was yes sir it was a three yes
sir the three i love it hey i want to
give a shout out to a couple people
though
um i think his name was sebastian he
said steph he had a nice stat line for
him he said steph is going to have 26
points seven assists and six rebounds he
was very specific
it was another guy that said steph is
gonna give us 32 and five assists
so we have some specific stat lines um
can we
can we can we bring up the five winners
who roll with uh los
on the maid last curry shot the last
five people that we sent home with money
low shout out to you you sent
10 people home with some cash tonight
that's a very sensitive so
let's go let's go so again a recap
of the winners uh 50 fresh prince
cool and eddie uh
sally all of them are taking home 200
and then we have our previous
winners from the first uh prompt which
was steph curry ten and a half threes
over
as los predicted and uh they are going
home with 500
a piece and then our last ones steph
curry makes shot to end it
200 a piece that is 10 people that's
going
home with money hey next tuesday we got
the jazz versus celtics
my boy lose and i will be giving away
more money look at this man
have you ever seen patrick beverly with
another
player's journey i don't think i'll let
you i'll let you i let you get away with
a lot of
jokes today because i'm scared
because i'm scared i'm really scared of
yellow jackets
bumblebees and that shirt you got on
remind me of it so i ain't wanna that's
why i'm kind of
you know i'll let you get a little past
today cause i'm scared of y'all way out
man
pep bears and pee wee plug we out
self dirty and famous lost we out
steph go for 32 tonight
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
you